**Susan Daniels***: Everyone welcome to the five day boot camp it's tremendously excited to see everyone today and be a part of this journey with you as we prepare to take a certification, that is recognized worldwide.
**Susan Daniels***: I want to recognize that Barbara walters is contributing to this boot camp through a lot of videos that she has prepared.
**Susan Daniels***: And I want to give her credit, even though you may not see her on screen today, she is very much contributor to the curriculum that will be covering.
**Susan Daniels***: Also, not on screen, but very much a part of this boot camp is our mentors the mentors are supporting us through the Q amp a and that leads me into when we should how we should use the technology that we have.
**Susan Daniels***: On your screen, you should see on the ability, at the very bottom, you should see a chat raise your hand and a Q amp a.
**Susan Daniels***: i'd appreciate, if you would use the chat to have interaction with your peers and with me and as we dialogue throughout this curriculum.
**Susan Daniels***: The Q amp a is for really trying to reach the mentors and for technical issues that may arise or guidance on how to access some of the materials that will be referenced today.
**Susan Daniels***: they're there to help you navigate if you will now from time to time, we may have discussions and cover concepts.
**Susan Daniels***: And you may have been distracted by something in your environment, let me give you an example let's say we're covering a resource on allocation matrix and a very special type of that is called a racy.
**Susan Daniels***: And while i'm covering what the acronyms for RNA and CNI cover you get distracted you to don't know what the C stands for.
**Susan Daniels***: Now you can put that question in the chat and maybe one of your peers will answer for you, but if you don't get an answer on a very specific point you can ask a mentor.
**Susan Daniels***: And they can give you a short answer clarification what i'm going to ask you to try to avoid when you're talking to the mentors is asking very specific questions about your project on how to apply a concept that score consulting then academic clarifications and mentoring.
**Susan Daniels***: As you will see in the chat they are putting on how to access, if you want to dial on through your phone if you need to move about during the day and still stay engaged.
**Susan Daniels***: Now please be patient with the Q amp a, although we have several mentors working with us to support this cohort there are literally hundreds of you joining, and it takes a lot of answer dozens and dozens of questions as they fly through.
**Susan Daniels***: What i'd like for you to do is to use the chat to share out if we cover a concept or a technique that you're familiar with.
**Susan Daniels***: It would be great say maybe what tool you're using or how you've seen it applied, because that augments the curriculum that makes it more of a learning experience for us all.
**Susan Daniels***: to learn and benefit from each other.
**Susan Daniels***: So.
**Susan Daniels***: Now that we've sort of talked about on how to use the tool in front of you let's talk about the materials that.
**Susan Daniels***: support this curriculum, we are going to go through a series of slides together in a couple of activities Q and a's on some dialogues and poll questions.
**Susan Daniels***: But it's based on the pmi learner kit and there is an entire video available out on your shared folders to get how to get your learner kit.
**Susan Daniels***: I want to caution you though don't goes directly and buy your learner kit please check with your training administrator first, because once you buy the kit, it is not refundable, but there are a lot of details relative data access this material through your shared folder.
**Susan Daniels***: But once you have your on your learner kit which starts with a voucher code, you have access to what is known as aloe choice, out of the pm, supported by pmi.
**Susan Daniels***: You will come to this screen, and this will be your panel on behind this will be a lot of the curriculum materials that you need to prepare for your exam.
**Susan Daniels***: The student manual is about 300 pages long, and it tracks, with the slides that we will be covering and suffer day five because on day five, we have a bonus session, where we go deep on agile it's a concentration on the agile methodology on day five.
**Susan Daniels***: All these lines that we use are available through your pmi camp, but what we've done is we've sprinkle them throughout the curriculum to introduce the concepts and then on day five we do a strong concentration on it, and some of those slides repeat.
**Susan Daniels***: I do want to introduce you to the concept of the project manager checklist this isn't a real important part of preparing for the exam.
**Susan Daniels***: behind it, you will see a series of what are called guidelines and for each major process that you're trying to do for project management, they have a guideline or a checklist that you should go through to know that you've executed that process well.
**Susan Daniels***: The course files are going to be on mostly the slides that we have available to you as well as how to get to some of the supporting material, we will ask for your support for a post.
**Susan Daniels***: course survey so that pmi knows on the satisfaction level of our students as an authorized training provider.
**Susan Daniels***: You will see some spotlight videos and these are really interesting and prepared by pmi themselves or high end production and very entertaining this short sweet, to the point, but loaded with useful information.
**Susan Daniels***: Do not skip these this isn't because they're produced by pmi there an excellent source for p&p exam prep.
**Susan Daniels***: Questions so it's a great place that on question writers go to to build out their question bank.
**Susan Daniels***: And the self knowledge check is an opportunity to have some mastery questions to test your knowledge.
**Susan Daniels***: So do you must, you have a learner kit well if you're simply taking this class because you want to learn about project management or you're trying to strengthen your skill set in project management, maybe already have your p&p and you want to look at what's current in the industry.
**Susan Daniels***: Look at what's new for the pen Bach and the pmt, this is a great class for that as well, you can get quite a few continuing education not continuing professional development units by participating in this class.
**Susan Daniels***: You will need the kit.
**Susan Daniels***: If you are following the pmi and the skill soft recommend two steps if you are going for a certificate of completion in this class and you want to use that certificate of completion from an authorized training provider the pmi kit is is required um.
**Susan Daniels***: If you have any additional questions regarding the arm the pmi cat Please see the video.
**Susan Daniels***: For additional details.
**Susan Daniels***: So the next is is attendance on about attendance, first of all, is very important, however, you sign in to use your full name and you consistently use that name threw out all sessions.
**Susan Daniels***: zoo aggregates your participation and it helps our mentors who are preparing your certificate of completion to be looking for the exact same name to be able to some your hours of participation.
**Susan Daniels***: Please do not log in as one person in a whole group of people watching because the group of people will not get.
**Susan Daniels***: counted for their participation so it's very important that each person sign in individually and signing consistently now, as you can see through the chat and moves rather rapidly, and you can watch it scroll through what i've done as well as our panelists is we have.
**Susan Daniels***: put our little Asterix by a name i'm going to type now here I go and you will see me come through with my picture and.
**Susan Daniels***: You should see the Asterix that before my name it may help you find my answers if i'm responding to questions as we go through this.
**Susan Daniels***: Oh great I see, we were people that are testing okay um don't use the Asterix if you are not a panelist okay that's just to help um you guys see our chats go through quicker.
**Susan Daniels***: So, now that we have attendance that you understand how to log in and how to use the tools that you have and the materials that you need let's talk about attendance.
**Susan Daniels***: This is a live boot camp experience and pmi requires that you participate in real time during this there is not a.
**Susan Daniels***: On demand version of this boot camp, you are to be engaged in real time for the duration.
**Susan Daniels***: If you should miss our need to step away, please understand that no more than 15 minutes can allow Apps before you are back engaged if you miss more than 15 minutes of any session, you will be required to have to go to the next live cohort and make up that session.
**Susan Daniels***: And the ability to arm to see these replays are on a case by case basis, by applying and requesting through the mentors So is there a maximum to how many missed sessions, you can have, yes, you can only have 115 minute missed session okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Then you have to go back and ask for the either the replay if it's just a very brief miss, but if you have been called into a meeting or a child is sick or you.
**Susan Daniels***: now have to go on business travel something interrupt your ability to do the entire cohort, then you could move to the next live boot camp, to make up those sessions again.
**Susan Daniels***: If you want to try to access the replay for very short recoveries of a concept, or two that may have been missed while perhaps your Internet was dropped Okay, then you petition the on the mentors using the.
**Susan Daniels***: skill soft at mentor skills off mentoring at skills soft calm, if you want to know when the next live boot camp will be this is the link to the calendar that will take you on with a posting of the next sessions.
**Susan Daniels***: So one of the questions is well, can you confirm, for me, I didn't really remember exactly how long I might have been off or.
**Susan Daniels***: When I might have missed for a phone call here or there stepped away unexpectedly.
**Susan Daniels***: No, we don't confirm on a per person per session basis, this is done zoom aggregates this at the end and we look at it in total so it's up to you to track your attendance Okay, and how that attendance sheet available to submit as part of your certificate of completion.
**Susan Daniels***: So.
**Susan Daniels***: Attendance tracker might look something like this it was simply say who you are and the date of the session that you're participating in and when did you log in.
**Susan Daniels***: And, did you have to log out for some reason, and then, when did you have a chance to log back in.
**Susan Daniels***: Well we're going to have several breaks in this on covert I mean it is all day long, so please know that you are strongly encouraged to stay logged in during the breaks.
**Susan Daniels***: That way, you don't have to worry about all your connectivity you don't have to worry about reef configuring your system.
**Susan Daniels***: During our morning breaks in our afternoon breaks your strongly encouraged just stay logged in, but if, for some reason you lose connectivity step away or your disrupted, please put this on your tracker.
**Susan Daniels***: Then you'll know what replays you may need to ask for, or what day you may need to go back and ask to visit the next live cohort.
**Susan Daniels***: So I mentioned the certificate of completion now there's a whole video on how to apply for your certificate of completion and it's available in your folders.
**Susan Daniels***: But please, know that part of that application process involves submitting and attaching your attendance tracker.
**Susan Daniels***: So you might as well start it get out a piece of paper or you can use a tracker I believe we have one out there on a template Carl, can you confirm for me in the chat whether there is a link to a word file that's.
**Susan Daniels***: A tracker.
**Susan Daniels***: colleges said yes so there's already a template available for you and i'm you're welcome to use it.
**Susan Daniels***: So, looking at the curriculum that will be we'll be covering most people think well it's based on the pen Bach of that would be true, but only partially true it's more than just the pen Bach.
**Susan Daniels***: It is based upon a wide array of.
**Susan Daniels***: resources that have been kind of canonized over the years, as the primary sources or leading tomes and standards and guides for project management.
**Susan Daniels***: If you are trying to access your pin box, you can of course try to get a one off of any online purveyor of books, but there is another way if you become a member of pmi dot O rg access to the standards is readily available to you in digital format.
**Susan Daniels***: Now the the version four on the seventh the sixth edition is being migrated all of the content is being migrated into what is known as pmi standards, plus and pmi standards, plus is provided to as a benefit of being a project on pmi that O rg Member.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm going to play a short video for you and i'm going to just make sure that i've got it shared for sound and optimized for clip.
**Susan Daniels***: Re sharing.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, so once we're done with this video i'm going to take you out to the pmi website and i'm going to show you how to access or access the pmi standards.
**Susan Daniels***: It is an awesome source that's available to you to help you advance your career, I use it, because sometimes I don't want to invent the wheel, and I can often go out there and find the fastest simplest easiest way to get something done or find a template that I may need.
To.
strengthen your skills and bring your next project to completion, with confidence.
Introducing pmi standards, plus a digital solution that gives you instant access to pmi standards and guides plus a whole lot more.
we've heard you and we're here to help you evolve your practice to meet the needs of today's projects.
Easy searchable access to pmi standards and guides is just the beginning, you also get exclusive access to how to Articles case studies and videos.
downloadable templates that you can use on your project right now real time updates to standards application so you can follow best practices and real world solutions, a personalized experience you create through playlists and learning opportunities to help you thrive on each project.
pmi standards, plus find the right content exactly when you need it and work with confidence check it out today.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, give me a moment.
**Susan Daniels***: And I want to show you.
**Susan Daniels***: This is personal to.
**Susan Daniels***: let's go to pmi standards.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, so once you like the pmi homepage and you've logged in you're going to see standards and publications, and these are available mini on them free as part of your.
**Susan Daniels***: Membership some of them are for purchase, but most are you can just get the digital version, you will see pmi standards over here.
**Susan Daniels***: And it just really is an awesome source, I just wanted to show you how to find it once you got your membership.
Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: So beyond just the pen Bach and the pmi standards there are.
Sorry.
**Susan Daniels***: There we go there is what I call what I referenced earlier, there is a wide array of fundamental resources that pmi pulls from.
**Susan Daniels***: To create the exam here is a list of them now before you start to run out and try to find all these books and try to figure out oh my God that's a lot of reading to do okay it's over $5,000 5000 pages of reading.
**Susan Daniels***: The advantage of using an authorized training provider and taking the tmp exam prep courses that all this information, the key elements of it have already been distilled into the slides and the student manual that will be using so a lot of the work is already been done for you.
**Susan Daniels***: So, now that you're aware of, on the the resource materials that you need and that you need to keep track of your engagement with this course through the tracker what.
**Susan Daniels***: What should I really expect is realistically what I have to do to get ready for the exam.
**Susan Daniels***: Now there is a video available for that as well and it tells you some exam prep tips, and it tells you how to apply for the for the exam, so I would encourage you to try to watch that perhaps on your lunch hour.
**Susan Daniels***: On but you go through the 35 hours of boot camp and this boot camp is fundamentally just an introduction and overview, if you will, of the content that you need on your own time to go deeper and study and internalize okay.
**Susan Daniels***: There are additional videos available to help you reinforce the concepts that are being presented in introduced here through their personal to when you're looking up the topics on make sure that it has the pmi.
**Susan Daniels***: update we've been preparing the tmp exam prep content on for several versions, you want to make sure you're looking at the one for this exam the 2021 exam version.
**Susan Daniels***: So, once you have gone through the boot camp review through the videos studied your user manual looked at your on your guidelines studied your vocabulary.
**Susan Daniels***: Then he should be ready to start taking mock test questions okay or your test prep questions and the goal is to try to get.
**Susan Daniels***: If you pull down 10 questions to try to get eight or more correct consistently, even if you're pulling down the same questions are governing some of the same concepts.
**Susan Daniels***: Over and over you want to get very confident very familiar with the vocabulary, the terms the processes, the tools and the techniques and the only way to do that is just reputation repetition and practice.
**Susan Daniels***: So one of the popular questions is well about how long should I study before I try to take the test well, there are various guidelines out there, depending on what authorized training provider you're engaged with, but there is it typically runs between i'm.
**Susan Daniels***: At least six to maybe 10 weeks okay there's a lot of concepts that need to be covered, so if you're looking anywhere between 40 and 100 hours of studying.
**Susan Daniels***: And it's up to you to try to set your own schedule to prepare for it but we'll cover that when we get closer to the end on how to really hammer down and get ready for next steps.
**Susan Daniels***: So we're now at the point.
**Susan Daniels***: Where we're going to see this kind of slide rather consistently, this is your agenda slide and again introduces to you the topics that we're going to be covering today.
**Susan Daniels***: And as you can see, we have a busy day Okay, tomorrow, we only cover a couple of topics, but we go very, very deep on scope and schedule.
**Susan Daniels***: So before we really launch into our curriculum, I wanted to know, do you have a question for me, I can see the chat just for me, do you have a question, and let me see if I can you know peruse them and just answer them live for you.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay um, the question is, can I be signed into multiple devices.
**Susan Daniels***: on that question is better answer to Q amp a but as long as you're using the same name okay um you may be able to.
**Susan Daniels***: To stay stay logged in but i'm going to ask Carl de or barb to clarify, on average, what is the percentage the pen test takers.
**Susan Daniels***: Past the first time they don't necessarily share that arm, how many pass, but I will let you know that it has a reputation of being rigorous.
**Susan Daniels***: And that there is a significant portion of people who didn't do the due diligence to really understand the vocabulary, the guidelines, what would I do next okay um.
**Susan Daniels***: So there is a significant portion of people who do not pass the first attempt, but there is also, you should still be optimistic if you follow the materials that are provided for you and you do the test prep work that you need to do, you can with confidence walk in and take the exam.
**Susan Daniels***: Thanks.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay um any other questions before I move right into the curriculum.
**Susan Daniels***: Yes, i'm roomies I can see your name spelled out both your first and last name.
**Susan Daniels***: Oh, if I missed part of the session to have to miss got to make up the whole five days and the next cohort on if you missed a.
**Susan Daniels***: Less less than 15 minutes you're okay in any one session, if you miss more than that and it's just a little more than that you may be able to ask for a replay opportunity, just to recover those concepts.
**Susan Daniels***: But if you miss significantly portions of the session, then you need to make up that session and then next live boot camp no you don't need to make up the whole boot camp you don't need to make up all the days that you actually didn't participate, you need to make up the day you missed.
Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: um.
**Susan Daniels***: Are the slides you were showing available to us, yes, they will be available to you, through your learning platform.
**Susan Daniels***: Are you able to see us no, I cannot see you I wish I could, because it will be so much more dynamic and I would be able to.
**Susan Daniels***: engage with you and see if you're laughing or see if you're you know you're scowling but no, I cannot see you, this is a webinar format so there's only the panelists that are that are sharing the video.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, any other questions.
**Susan Daniels***: How is engagement tracks, so that we can be sure it doesn't register is inactive on in 15 minutes stay logged in you need to stay logged in okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, so give me a moment i'm going to take a SIP of water and we'll get started into the curriculum.
**Susan Daniels***: So, according to our agenda we're really going to focus today on creating a high performing team.
**Susan Daniels***: Because the understanding of how to build the resources, you need to get started, is foundational to success.
**Susan Daniels***: there's been a lot of arm debate discussion going on within the pmi community of whether we should change our profession title from project management to project leadership.
**Susan Daniels***: which puts more emphasis on recognizing what the definition of leadership is, which is to get a group of people to share a common vision.
**Susan Daniels***: Which is to get a group of people to work together to achieve a common vision which is pretty much what we're trying to do as project managers so let's talk about what it takes to build a team.
**Susan Daniels***: You acquire it and develop it so i'm going to talk to you for a moment about the structure of the curriculum and what you're going to see rather consistently the curriculum is designed divided, as we saw into five major lessons.
**Susan Daniels***: These five lessons then have different tasks that we are trying to learn how to do and do well, so to do that we need to understand what kind of tools and techniques or enablers that we may need to be successful in achieving that tasks.
**Susan Daniels***: All of the work all of the tasks that a project manager does is organized into three process groups.
**Susan Daniels***: are also known as high level knowledge areas today we're going to be working with the people processes, the people tasks the other.
**Susan Daniels***: domain is processes, we will spend quite a bit of time tomorrow on processes and then we'll move back to working with how to work with people and get the best results from them.
**Susan Daniels***: So, as people processes and then keeping the business in mind Okay, the macro environment in which we're trying to.
**Susan Daniels***: On.
**Susan Daniels***: The macro environments we're trying to work I just saw a bar put something in chat she's asking that you guys, please not do a name check with us through chat um.
**Susan Daniels***: If you've typed your full name in you should be fine on the way that you would be able to change your name is off from the arm, where you see.
**Susan Daniels***: your ability to type yes.
**Barb Waters**: I am so sorry to.
**Barb Waters**: interrupt I.
**Barb Waters**: want to let you know in this environment students are not able to rename themselves as a setting and zoom.
**Barb Waters**: You, we need to reach out to you, but unfortunately the chat is so clogged right now with tests.
**Barb Waters**: that the only two students out of the 820 who are in this class I can't access I can't reach them because we're clogging the chat.
**Barb Waters**: I only need to reach out to fran and Viola right now that's it everybody else if you could please just don't test if it's wrong, we see it, and we'll find you everybody else looks great Thank you so much.
**Susan Daniels***: Spar thanks for your technical support there, thank you.
**Susan Daniels***: So your curriculum is divided into knowledge on into domains people processes and keeping the business in mind, then it's divided into lessons and the lessons each lesson has a task the task has enablers so what would that actually look like.
**Susan Daniels***: Well let's take a look sorry happy finger here i'm creating a high performing team that's our first lesson.
**Susan Daniels***: These are the tasks that we are going to focus on over the next few minutes Okay, and then you are going to see this slide format frequently what you're looking at, are some of the tools and techniques and products that are produced, while trying to execute this task.
**Susan Daniels***: This is a study slide what you want to be able to do with this slide is to.
**Susan Daniels***: basically cover up build a team and go Okay, if I see these tools and techniques and these enablers what task, am I trying to accomplish and you should be able to recall that is building a team or, conversely, if you have built a team can you recall what sort of skills.
**Susan Daniels***: tools tasks and outputs you're going to produce when you're trying to do this.
**Susan Daniels***: These should be reviewed frequently on in your preparation okay being able to align the enablers to the task.
**Susan Daniels***: So when we're talking about building a team we're really talking about resource management and resource management is beyond just what you might think of desktop capabilities power tools vehicles.
**Susan Daniels***: heavy equipment it's also the human resources and we're going to start with the human resource for first because projects are done through people, and we need to get the best talent, that we can get for the resources we have available to us.
**Susan Daniels***: So when you're trying to build a team, you want to start with, you need to estimate what you need.
**Susan Daniels***: Then figure out how you're going to acquire it because that might take some negotiation can I get the 18 from in house or am I going to get the Deity you know available is not necessarily a skill.
**Susan Daniels***: And then we'll get into how you manage the team that you've gone out and said you needed acquired negotiated for and then, how do you manage them, you have to develop them as well we'll get into some of the training requirements and how do we deal with that.
**Susan Daniels***: And not only do we have to have our team bill, we got to be effective and leading them communicating them and what kind of tools will we be involved.
**Susan Daniels***: To be effective, leaders of our teams and, of course, every leader also has to monitor and control performance and deal with on resolving issues as they're identifying so let's get started on this.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm just giving you a moment to look at this now.
**Susan Daniels***: One of the things that you have to start out with is what skills Do I need I need.
**Susan Daniels***: Given the objectives of my project what skills must I have.
**Susan Daniels***: enabling me to execute.
**Susan Daniels***: One thing that I if you come in, if you're following along and you're taking notes a key point here is avoid a single point of failure, in other words, only having one tester but, if your tester is got covered that could very much delay the final product and delivery of your product.
**Susan Daniels***: So, to the extent possible try to identify a backup a secondary and alternate to each of your resources that you need you may not need to call on it, but a good planning would always have a contingency plan and alternate.
**Susan Daniels***: When you're looking at your team and trying to pull the best players, yes, you want people with specific skills sorry specific skills that's a little tricky to say.
**Susan Daniels***: You want them to be strong and go deep on what the talent that you need but take into consideration, people who have more than just that skill people who can play.
**Susan Daniels***: In other roles Okay, they have more generalized skills so maybe you have a developer, but they can also test or write test cases Okay, that would be looking at a specialist but just got some more generalized abilities.
**Susan Daniels***: Now.
**Susan Daniels***: you're also responsible for not just getting the people, the human resources you're going to be responsible for getting all of their supporting and enabling tools as well, so.
**Susan Daniels***: Part of project management is learning how to get your resources setup if you need to set up desktop capabilities and authorize all of the administrative access is that they need for them to do their job that's part of your role.
**Susan Daniels***: Knowing that you need to get that done and knowing how to navigate the organization to get them the access that they need, are you the one that's responsible for getting all of the resources delivered to the site on time to meet their needs, so that they are not waiting on site.
**Susan Daniels***: for lack of a power tool that they need you're responsible for both the human resources and all of the enabling tools that they may need.
**Susan Daniels***: um I pulled out specifically their access rights because frequently on project managers who are new to their role.
**Susan Daniels***: i've never felt that they were responsible for that right, it was always done by somebody else well.
**Susan Daniels***: Now it's your your problem to solve you've brought them on the team, they need to be operational so be cognizant then getting them all of the access that they need from day one, is an essential task.
**Susan Daniels***: If you come across a scenario in your P amp T and they're talking about setting up the systems for joe's project.
**Susan Daniels***: And tina's on access they're going to ask you what task may you be trying to accomplish they may be asking you what process you're trying to do the task would be build your team, the process to be human you know resource management, you need to know how this all fits together.
**Susan Daniels***: So let's say that you've successfully estimated your team and you're acquiring them and you're resourcing them but there's more than just your team, there are project, stakeholders and for those of you taking notes, this is a good one okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Project stakeholders are any person or organization.
**Susan Daniels***: That is or perceives that it is impacted by your projects processes or outcomes we repeat that stakeholder is any person or organization.
**Susan Daniels***: That is or perceives that it is impacted by your projects processes or outcomes and, if you think about that that is about as broad as an umbrella, as you can come up with for really trying to figure out who my care.
**Susan Daniels***: Now.
**Susan Daniels***: is pretty easy to think about who are the stakeholders that readily come to mind, but you want to also think a little broader, which is who would care if this went horribly wrong.
**Susan Daniels***: With the police care with Channel four news care with the news care, would the local hospital care okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Who can be potential stakeholders for my project if it goes horribly wrong.
**Susan Daniels***: That can she thinking, maybe neighbors competition, the media federal regulatory agencies, the Community okay think way beyond just inside your shop Okay, they are working in who could potentially be your stakeholders.
**Susan Daniels***: But not only think negative but think opportunistically who would possibly care if this went amazingly well.
**Susan Daniels***: When we maybe get some some media in a trade journal, or on the news or might we get promotions or recognition okay i'm some way.
**Susan Daniels***: Who could care, who would want to know who could I tell Okay, if this project went very, very well and do I want to start to put that into my communication plan.
**Susan Daniels***: All TEAM members are stakeholders.
**Susan Daniels***: But not all stakeholders are TEAM members all TEAM members are stakeholders, because they very much are impacted by this projects processes and bias outcome okay TEAM members help you move the ball TEAM members help you execute.
**Susan Daniels***: Stakeholders care, but they might not help you execute it all.
**Susan Daniels***: Do regulatory bodies actually help you get the job done maybe not but they're very involved would your senior leadership.
**Susan Daniels***: They care, but many of them aren't necessarily going to to help you execute so they're stakeholders, but they're not TEAM members.
**Susan Daniels***: So we going to talk now for the next couple of minutes about what on about stakeholders.
**Susan Daniels***: i've given you some helpful hints about identifying stakeholders, but let's pause here and look at the slide from pmi.
**Susan Daniels***: So when do you start to identify your stakeholders it's one of the very first things you do.
**Susan Daniels***: When you're taking the exam.
**Susan Daniels***: Please understand that identify stakeholders is one of the very, very first things that you do.
**Susan Daniels***: It starts with the project charter.
**Susan Daniels***: And the project charter is really that document that is used for you, the project manager to understand what the project sponsors are really asking you to execute and it sets up some clarifications we'll go into that in greater detail tomorrow, when we talk about scope management.
**Susan Daniels***: But you started in the beginning, and this is so good point for me to tell you that when you're taking the arm the plp.
**Susan Daniels***: it's not a recall and recognition test it has a lot of that in there, I mean you have to be able to recall and recognize the vocabulary recall and recognize the different enablers.
**Susan Daniels***: But a lot of it is scenario based, and it is really asking you what would I do next, or if i'm doing this, what tools, what I want to use that gets back to your enablers.
**Susan Daniels***: And if I just did this, what potentially what I be looking to do next, and that gets back to your checklist and your guidelines, so you really do want to study those vigorously.
**Susan Daniels***: But when you get back to analyzing your stakeholders.
**Susan Daniels***: You want to look far and wide and you want to start from the beginning and you want to ask your sponsors who do they see as potential.
**Susan Daniels***: Stakeholders because they may be aware of players that you've never heard of before, and they can sensitize you to who you need to start adding to your communication plan and your stakeholder management plan.
**Susan Daniels***: Excuse me a minute, but if you're having trouble kind of getting started on identifying your stakeholders, you may want to look at previous projects, you may want to look at.
**Susan Daniels***: On if you picked up a project midterm you can look at their issue logs and see who the players were with the issues you look at the change management requests and who they are.
**Susan Daniels***: um you can look at all of the reports that are in play, and where they're coming from that can help you and who they're being distributed to the distribution list by looking at the work in progress.
**Susan Daniels***: You ultimately want to create a master stakeholder register.
**Susan Daniels***: On.
**Susan Daniels***: This master say quarter register is fundamentally little more than a table Okay, and this table.
**Susan Daniels***: We we've talked about.
**Susan Daniels***: You organize them into a table or into a grid, if you will, and there are different things you capture not just their name and their role and how to get Ahold of them, and why they might care, but you may want to assess them on other factors.
**Susan Daniels***: You may want to look at them on what is the power level as far as influencing okay how.
**Susan Daniels***: They might be a senior vice Vice President, well, what is their interest well they're only going to care if something goes wrong or impacts them right but they could.
**Susan Daniels***: Have the third phase of this project, potentially be impacted so for the first two phases their interest levels low, but their power still remains high.
**Susan Daniels***: power and influence there are people who have a lot of power, but they may not choose to exercise it.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, or if they do choose to exercise it are they very influential.
**Susan Daniels***: There are other people have very low low power but they're very influential in your organization they're a go to person or opinion is respected, so you need some great to arm to indicate that on your power and influence so there's different ways that you can assess evaluate your stakeholders.
**Susan Daniels***: on ways of identify him can also just be not only asking the experts that are already around you, but you can hold meetings and brainstorm who might be people that would care about your project.
**Susan Daniels***: Because the last thing you really want is someone popping up unexpectedly self identifying why they care and they're not happy, so you want to proactively identify who can be very interested and powerfully influential in your project here's an example of a stakeholder register.
**Susan Daniels***: it's very straightforward, this is not valid way to do it is just a way to do it let's take let's go ahead and look at a video on stakeholder identification and collaboration.
**Susan Daniels***: to that.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm going to go out to present to where you can go, many of you can and.
Sorry.
**Susan Daniels***: they're both green.
**Susan Daniels***: again.
**Susan Daniels***: You have the ability to create playlists.
**Susan Daniels***: And you can organize them to align with topics, or you can have them aligned by the day that should other resources that curriculum that you're studying.
also be a key stakeholder after all.
Within the people domain, the project manager must empower TEAM members and stakeholders and make sure that they are adequately trained.
will also collaborate with and mentor stakeholders, as appropriate, but this all begins with identifying who the stakeholders are.
A stakeholder can be any person or organization, who can influence your project or be influenced by it, that could be almost anyone, so we want to take the time to really think about the reach of our project.
Internally, the project team, including you, the project manager will be stakeholders so will anyone who works in operations and your sponsor will also be a key stakeholder.
After all, they are the person who will help provide you the necessary funds and who will have certain levels of authority that you may need to seek from time to time for project decisions.
Then we have the external environment of the project stakeholders can include suppliers society government creditors end users and customers.
All of these individuals and groups may interact with your project in some way, and we need to not only identify them but also determine how they might interact with the project and team.
Since there can be so many stakeholder individuals and groups that can interact with your project it's important to determine how you'll work with each stakeholder.
In fairness, you probably don't have all the resources and time that you would need to have personal and individual interactions with each and every stakeholder.
So we can perform a stakeholder analysis in order to categorize stakeholders by certain criteria.
In this example, we see an analysis based on the stakeholders level of involvement and level of influence stakeholders with high involvement and high influence should be managed closely.
stakeholders with high involvement, but low influence should be kept satisfied stakeholders with high influence, but low involvement should be kept informed.
And finally, stakeholders with low involvement and low influence should be monitored.
This particular matrix is just an example and you can exchange the criteria with other characteristics about your stakeholders.
For instance, you can perform stakeholder analysis using power and interest power and influence or influence and impact.
You could even use a 3D salience model, which adds a third axis, so it becomes a three dimensional sphere with power urgency and legitimacy as the characteristics.
keep in mind that stakeholder attitudes and positions can change stakeholders can join together to have a louder voice and increased power.
or stakeholders may suddenly become interested in a project that they previously didn't care much about stakeholder analysis is ongoing will need to regularly assess our stakeholders and their attitudes toward our project.
**Susan Daniels***: One stakeholders have been identified and analyzed it's helpful to keep them in a stakeholder register in this particular example we're tracking the stakeholders name.
**Susan Daniels***: Contact information their department or position which can include internal and external stakeholders, and it also includes their role in the project their requirements from the project and their expectations from the project.
**Susan Daniels***: After performing the stakeholder analysis, you can also add the stakeholder classification which reminds you of what type of interaction, you might have with the stakeholder in order to keep them engaged in the project.
**Susan Daniels***: The stakeholder register is a living document will regularly reassess our stakeholder situation and update this document as needed.
As mentioned the stakeholder register should be reevaluated and updated regularly because stakeholder engagement can change, for example, low power stakeholders may leverage relationships in order to gain more influence.
Also, we need to maintain an issue log for the project, the purpose of an issue log is to keep track of stakeholder issues and concerns and to document the status of these issues and any actions we've taken.
Keeping stakeholders committed requires senior manager.
Keeping steak.
**Susan Daniels***: hey we're about five minutes away from a break i'm just going to cover a slide or two and then we'll take a break.
**Susan Daniels***: So, now that we've identified our our team we've estimated them we've acquired them we're now we've got the resources they need to enable them to be successful.
**Susan Daniels***: If you have a very large and complex team sometimes it's very helpful to create something called a racy.
**Susan Daniels***: A racy is is a form of a resource assignment matrix also acronyms around and they're all different kinds of rams are resource assignment matrix since you can create a racy is only one version but it happens to be extremely popular.
**Susan Daniels***: oftentimes a senior leader will ask the racy for your project.
**Susan Daniels***: This is so if they walk into a meeting, and they have the racy they know who's in the room, and what their role is and why they care or how they're contributing okay so races, are very common products that are produced as part of building your team.
**Susan Daniels***: The test questions often have to do with what do the acronym our ACI stand for, and they can ask him in a variety of ways, they will often give you misleading ones like consult can be concerned or collaborate or chief right instead of consultant.
**Susan Daniels***: So it's important that you learn exactly these words are the equivalent in your language.
**Susan Daniels***: So let's talk about what each one means responsible is really someone who is working on the project and is responsible for some task, or some activity okay.
**Susan Daniels***: But they usually report to somebody else who is more accountable for all of the work that is being done in that division or in that space so there's only one accountable person per task of me per deliverable but there can be multiple people that are responsible for getting it done.
**Susan Daniels***: It tells question is often that there can be multiple people accountable true or false.
**Susan Daniels***: False only one person can be accountable, although multiple can be responsible.
**Susan Daniels***: Now consult is somebody who isn't necessarily going to contribute directly are execute any work on your behalf, but you.
**Susan Daniels***: consult them for their knowledge, their experience further advice or direction right they are helping you to plan, they are helping you to navigate and succeed.
**Susan Daniels***: oftentimes many part of your governance board are in the consultant role Okay, or you may have subject matter experts that are able to do the work for you they're already assigned.
**Susan Daniels***: But you still need their level of experience to come in for a meeting or two to advise and then they're back assigned to their regular their pre existing work so they're only consulting.
**Susan Daniels***: But they don't actually responsible for giving you anything.
**Susan Daniels***: Unfortunately project managers spend quite a bit of time trying to get people who just wanted to consult to actually be responsible, but that's a whole nother story for another day.
**Susan Daniels***: Informed informed are people that want to be on a distribution list to be made aware of the progress and status of your project.
**Susan Daniels***: But they're not coming to your meetings they're not producing the work for you, they just want to be aware this is often the managers manager.
**Susan Daniels***: Of whoever's team you're actually having work with you on your project they they want to know that things are going well, if things get early warnings of things are not, but they are being consultants are not responsible and they're certainly not directly accountable.
**Susan Daniels***: And it's really helpful again the more complex and more players your project have, the more valuable this racy becomes.
**Susan Daniels***: I will put on a nother video, and we can watch it and then we'll go to break.
**Susan Daniels***: Keeping stakeholders can read it requires senior.
**Susan Daniels***: day one.
**Susan Daniels***: of decisions associated with it, this person doesn't necessarily need to be consulted before work on.
**Susan Daniels***: When this is done, consider the tools and techniques, you can use when planning your project resources is data representation and one especially useful method is the racy chart.
**Susan Daniels***: This list work packages from the work breakdown structure down one side and the names of resources from the organizational breakdown structure across the top one of four letters identifies each person's roles and responsibilities.
The letter R identifies the person who owns an activity or is responsible for performing the work it includes.
The letter a identifies who must sign off or approve work before it is effective, in other words the person who is accountable for successful completion of a deliverable or work package.
The letter C identifies who has the information or the capability needed to complete a deliverable or work package, it shows, who should be approached to provide input to the work or to decisions that need to be made during an activity, the C stands for consult.
The letter I identifies who must be informed of the progress or results of an activity or of decisions associated with it, this person doesn't necessarily need to be consulted before work on an activity starts.
suppose you want to know who is responsible for testing the software in a development project to do this, you go to the test software row and look across until you find the letter R in this case F Phillips, is the person responsible for testing software.
or racy chart helps ensure that each element of work and the project scope is assigned to an individual who will be responsible for it.
It presents a lot of different information in a one page easy to use format, however, it doesn't give any detail about positions or how to carry out the activities.
To create a racy chart you follow three steps one list the project activities from the work breakdown structure down the first column of the table.
To list staff members from the organizational breakdown structure across the top row as column headings and three match activities with project staff roles and responsibilities, using the racy attributes.
To ensure that the right mix of roles is assigned it's best practice to ensure that only one person is assigned to the accountability for each activity, ideally, this person should not be the same person who was assigned responsibility for the activity.
You don't have to use the racy designations, you can create your own legend to communicate responsibilities, based on the nature of your project, for example, you could specify a legend that assigns letters for those who are accountable and to creators up daters and reviewers.
have to decisions associated with it.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay we're gonna go on break now it's a 15 minute break.
**Susan Daniels***: For 15 minutes and I will see you back in about 15 minutes stay logged in.